if the Jurassic Park thumps have taught
us one thing it's that life always finds
a way and if they've taught us two
things it's stopped going an island full
of dinosaurs there's some dangerous guys
rod munch Stephen er just watch the
movies which is why we combed through
the Jurassic world fallen kingdom
trailer to find all the best secret
nuggets and facts boy the first trailer
gives us a bunch of clues as to the
storyline of fallen Kingdom the
dinosaurs of Isla Nublar have been
allowed to take over the island and roam
free over the ruins of the Jurassic
world park which has been abandoned and
you can tell Jay world got emptied out
in a hurry a lot of the old busted gyro
spheres are just laying around and
there's even still Dino merch on the
shelves in the shops but that one's
actually a real dinosaur fallen Kingdom
it seems concerns a rescue mission
apparently Jurassic world was built on
top of an active volcano
oopsy-daisy and all the dinosaurs are
going to die again just like a million
years ago is that one the Jurassic
period was so Claire convinces Owen to
return to the island and save blue the
Velociraptor he helped raise and train
blue is alive blue you'll recall is the
only survivor out of her pack her fellow
Raptors echo Delta and Charlie all died
during the action of Jurassic world
hashtag r.i.p Delta or Charlie or echo
or whichever ones on fire right now Rexy
the t-rex who blue fought with during
the film's exciting conclusion also
reappears in this new movie that's her
lying down in the back of the truck
presumably being shipped off the island
to where last time they got sent to San
Diego and destroyed my hometown it's
still a little salty about that one
Rexy is the same Tyrannosaurus who was
featured in the original Jurassic Park
film she single-handedly is keeping this
franchise alive
she's like the rock of dinosaurs
fun fact fallen kingdom is the first
time Rexy has been realized on screen as
a practical effect rather than animation
since the original Jurassic Park in 1993
it also looks like Jurassic world's
Carnotaurus not only survived but
thrived to the present day before
apparently being eaten
this marks the fan-favorite dinos first
appearance in a Jurassic Park movie but
it's been in a bunch of the video games
cuz it's a horned t-rex so obviously
there's also a very clear Stegosaurus in
one of the shipping containers in the
trailer this is a dinosaur that appeared
in every Jurassic Park film but usually
with a relatively small role one
exception the famed Sega's skirmish
scene from the lost world that opening
song on the jukebox as anyone who knows
what love is will understand by our
Mitama s-- an interesting connection is
this song was featured frequently in the
TV series black mayor and Bryce Dallas
Howard starred in her own episode of
Black Mirror seems far too coincidental
for this old nerd if you listen closely
you can also hear bit of the strings
from the original Jurassic Park theme
playing throughout the trailer they
really bring it up at the end for
dramatic effect it's one of the several
callbacks to the original film series
throughout the new trailer this dramatic
shot of the t-rex and full roar recalls
the big epic moment from the first
Jurassic Park movie when the t-rex takes
over the visitors center remember that
little banner falling that says when
dinosaurs ruled the earth
irony also remember the original movie
Stampede scene with all those Gallimimus
bearing down on Dr Grant Lex and Tim
well we've got another Stampede scene in
this new film and it even features the
main characters diving for safety behind
a log is it the same log kind of looks
like it but perhaps everyone's favorite
callback actor Jeff Goldblum reprising
the role of mathematician /ko Titian dr.
Ian Malcolm for the first time since the
lost world in 1997 it looks like he's
smart enough to avoid going to the
island for the third time and is instead
testifying at some kind of hearing his
crew
were here before us he does recall the
famous life finds a way line from the
original film life finds away wow that's
a lot of tidbits and factoids about it
single movie trailer you might even say
we spared no expense remember you get in
the first movie anytime
Hammond showed them her you know I
forget it just watch the trailer
[Music]